the rule of law is what these people are
demanding
they came to the palace of justice to
show support for a judge who is facing a
political backlash
for charging the caretaker prime
minister hassan dieb
and former ministers with negligence
over the beirut port explosion
fadi sawan was supposed to question them
this week but the defendants
accuse him of violating the constitution
by overstepping his powers
and are refusing to comply it's his move
either he takes a decision
that shows that he is truly working for
justice in lebanon
or he don't do that and this shows that
the whole
decision that he took and everything
that happened in the past two weeks was
just
another scenario the case is now
politicized
leading politicians and religious
officials friends
and foes rallied behind dieb accusing
sowen of bypassing parliament
and are calling his decision selective
justice
the judge some say someone could have
avoided criticism if he explained that
more officials will be charged against
him fadi sawan has
the jurisdiction to indict
and to file a claim
against anybody once
the judge has submitted to the
parliament
now i think he has the total
and complete jurisdiction jurisdiction
over the port
was in the hands of many security
agencies ministries and political
parties
and the ammonium nitrate blamed for
triggering the explosion
was stored in warehouse 12 since late
2013.
that is why some politicians believe the
charges are
about settling political scores they
question why former ministers linked to
president michelle own for example
have not been charged the president has
denied accusations that he
intervened in the judicial probe the
families of the 200 people killed
believe
charges of negligence are not enough and
that many more officials need to provide
answers
we want justice for the blood of the
victims we want to know who caused the
death of our children
we are with you sawan in a country with
a history of a lack of accountability
and the judiciary long accused of being
politicized this
is unchartered territory but justice
here
is now at stake senator al-jazeera
beirut